this is the moment a Chinese Coast Guard
ship used water cannon on a civilian
vessel chartered by the Philippine Navy
it was one of two boats on the resupply
mission to Second Thomas show where
Filipino troops are stationed in a
decommissioned Navy ship which was sunk
nearly 25 years ago to stake their
nation's claim in the South China Sea
officials say both were blocked by China
along with two Coast Guard vessels
the Philippine vessels were subjected to
repeated water canyoning and continuous
dangerous Maneuvers by the Chinese Coast
Guard and Chinese militia vessels
placing the lives of the crew of the
Philippines vessels in danger in
violation of humanitarian and
international law in February the
Philippines said the Chinese Navy
pointed a military-grade laser at
Filipino Sailors causing temporary
blindness in the months following that
incident the two sides had at least two
other close calls at sea
the Philippine Coast Guard says this is
nothing new
but under President Ferdinand Marcus Jr
they're encouraged to publicize it
Marcos has pivoted back to a more U.S
friendly foreign policy allowing U.S
troops access to the country's basis in
sharp contrast with his predecessor
Rodrigo duterte's pro-china stance this
is far from the first time the
Philippines has accused China of
harassing Filipino vessels in the south
of China Sea government leaders in
Manila have already filed dozens of
diplomatic protests against Beijing this
year and nearly 450 since 2020
the Chinese Coast Guard insists the
Philippine vessels enter Chinese Waters
illegally the Philippine foreign
Ministry has summoned the Chinese
Ambassador and says it will keep
protesting as long as it has to
it's very clear as they said not one
inch of our territory should actually be
handed over to our to China
foreign allies like Japan Australia and
the European Union were quick to condemn
China and stress the legally binding
nature of a 2016 International ruling
that decision invalidated beijing's
sweeping claims into South China Sea it
was based on the United Nations
convention on the law of the sea to
which China is a signatory the U.S state
department has also stressed its
commitment to defend its longtime Ally
if the need arises Barn below Al Jazeera
Manila
foreign